you shall sign here chanting vote in
China's Parliament are never in doubt
and neither was this delegates in
Beijing dutifully approved the proposal
for a national security law for Hong
Kong there was one vote against offered
up as a fig leaf for Chinese democracy
you should either one country two
systems is the fundamental policy of the
country the central government has
always emphasized the comprehensive and
accurate implementation of one country
two systems' Hong Kong ruling Hong Kong
and it's high degree of autonomy
if only Hong Kong's Parliament the
Legislative Council were as obedient
today there were familiar scuffles
legislators were actually debating a
different bill one which would outlaw
insulting the Chinese national anthem
not the national security law and that's
the entire point Hong Kong's parliament
has no say in the national security law
it is being imposed directly by Beijing
activists feared the national security
law will curb Hong Kong's traditional
freedoms of the press of Association of
protest freedoms unavailable on the
Chinese mainland the Hong Kong
government and said that the city's
autonomy will be preserved but the u.s.
doesn't agree Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo said the US government no longer
viewed Hong Kong as autonomous from
China a status it has held since the
handover from the UK in 1997 and was
supposed to hold for 50 years it could
mean Hong Kong loses its special trading
and financial status and that sanctions
could be applied that would prompt more
furious reaction from Beijing the people
of Hong Kong though are left in between
uncertain and afraid as the clever hopes
expire Tom Cheshire Sky News Beijing